(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar o que acontece
se o imóvel que você arrematou em leilão
ex-prejudicial estiver alugado.
Bom, se o imóvel estiver alugado, você deve
proceder com a denúncia do contrato de locação.
O que significa denunciar um contrato de locação?
Significa nada mais do que você notificar o
locatário, ou seja, o inquilino daquele imóvel, que
você não tem mais interesse em manter aquele
contrato de locação.
Então, uma vez arrematado o imóvel em leilão
ex-prejudicial, estando esse imóvel alugado, você, como
arrematante, deve escolher se quer ou não manter
aquele contrato.
Caso você escolha por encerrar aquele contrato, aquele
contrato de locação não é um contrato que
te interesse, você deve realizar essa denúncia do
contrato de locação.
Essa denúncia deverá ser realizada até 90 dias
após a consolidação da propriedade em seu nome,
ou seja, até 90 dias após o registro
do imóvel em seu nome, você deverá denunciar
esse contrato de locação.
Realizando a denúncia do contrato de locação, você
deve oferecer um prazo de até 30 dias
para que esse locatário, o inquilino, saia do
imóvel.
Agora, um detalhe importante.
Caso você escolha manter o contrato de locação
porque você acha interessante aquele valor pelo qual
aquele imóvel está alugado, ou caso você escolha
acabar com aquele contrato de locação realizando a
denúncia do contrato, você tem direito a receber
o valor daquela locação enquanto o locatário estiver
naquele imóvel.
E você tem direito a receber esse valor
desde quando?
Você tem direito a receber esse valor desde
o dia que você realizou a arrematação, ou
seja, desde a data da arrematação.
Não é necessário que você espere o registro
completo da arrematação em seu nome, ou seja,
o registro do imóvel em seu nome, para
você requerer que o aluguel seja pago a
você e não ao antigo proprietário.
Então, a partir da data da realização do
leilão, você já pode fazer esse requerimento para
que você comece a receber o valor desse
aluguel.
Caso o locatário não saia desse imóvel ao
final do período de 30 dias que você
concedeu para desocupação do imóvel, vai ser necessário
você ingressar com uma ação de despejo no
Poder Judiciário para que o Poder Judiciário coloque
esse locatário para fora.
Mas antes disso, vale tudo aquilo que a
gente falou na desocupação do imóvel em leilão
extrajudicial.
Primeiro, você deve tentar sempre uma forma amigável,
um acordo para que a pessoa desocupe o
imóvel.
Caso esse acordo não seja cumprido, e aí
é que no caso da locação do imóvel,
esse acordo vai ser exatamente esses 30 dias
que você vai dar para essa pessoa sair
do imóvel, esses 30 dias que você deve
oferecer para que a pessoa tenha a oportunidade
de procurar um outro lugar para ela morar.
Só após isso, você deve entrar na Justiça.
Aqui nessa aula, também vou deixar o modelo
de uma ação de despejo de um contrato
de locação para que, se necessário, você recorra
a esse modelo e você leve para um
advogado também realizar o protocolo dessa ação na
Justiça.
Com esse modelo, eu também acredito que vocês
podem reduzir os custos de solidariedade de um
advogado exatamente porque você já vai levar o
modelo preenchido com seus dados, com os dados
da arrematação e o advogado vai ter o
trabalho de revisar essa petição inicial e dar
a entrada nessa petição inicial.
Então, recapitulando, caso você arremate um imóvel em
leilão extrajudicial e se esse imóvel estiver alugado,
a primeira coisa que você deve fazer é
denunciar esse contrato, caso você não tenha interesse
em realizar esse contrato recebendo o valor dessa
locação.
Você deve denunciar esse contrato num prazo de
90 dias após a consolidação da propriedade em
seu nome, ou seja, após o registro do
imóvel em seu nome e conceder um prazo
de 30 dias para que o locatário saia
do imóvel.
Somente se ele não sair, você ainda assim
deve tentar mais algum acordo amigável com ele
para que ele desocupe seu imóvel e, caso
ele não desocupe, somente nesse caso você entrará
com essa ação à justiça.